why did you get it so big a that's what
she said
does the skin look red and swollen
that's what she said
that's my joke damn it dwight eat it eat
it phyllis dip it in the water so it'll
slide down your gullet more easily
oh no just come on you guys let's do it
i need two men on this that's what she
said no time but she did no
time okay you know what i want you to
think about your future
at this company i want you to think
about it long and hard that's what she
said
don't you dare
i'll be your first customer you're
hardly my first
that's what she said that's what she
said
that's what who's that i never know
let me just say it i can't believe you
came
that's what you said
santiago i know that you hate halloween
but stick with me and i promise you you
will love it
can you magically make everyone kind
sober and fully dressed
kind sober and fully dressed good news
everyone we found the name of santiago
sex tape
i'm horrible at this when can we stop
i'm horrible at this one
no i know title of my sex tape yeah well
done
title of my sex tape as long as we're
clear that i'm with someone and nothing
is gonna
i'm with someone nothing's gonna happen
name your sex tape he's back
geek blast of cold air coming out of
that box
name of amy's sex tape hey man come on
not cool
i'm going through something just let me
have this one we broke a rule
yeah i hope it wasn't a mistake hope it
wasn't a mistake title your sex tape
title of our sex tape ben
come meet jerry's wife gail
happy holidays chris so good to see you
i have someone i'd like you to meet
i'm gail gergich
gail your gail jerry's beautiful wife
who looks like that gayle i hope you're
not in
any way uncomfortable that i'm here
since i dated your daughter oh
not at all you're welcome here at any
time
so gail and jerry i've thought about it
a lot there's no logical explanation
it is so wonderful to be part of such a
special day okay remember under no
circumstances can leslie know about
what's going on
she has to make that face do you
understand well i don't fully but
my lips are sealed i asked for larry's
help because he has the most successful
marriage of anyone i know
to a gorgeous woman which honestly is
still a mystery to me
like was it a hypnosis accident or
something where they put gail under and
made her fall in love with larry and
never said the magic word to snap her
out of it
like if i say nutmeg will she wake up
and start screaming
wait while you were at jerry's did you
happen to get any information about his
history with gail like was she a russian
spy
and the kgb forced her to marry jerry as
a cover
you know it's a mystery ben let it go
yeah i can't it keeps me awake at night
hey maybe gail has one of those oliver
sex brain disorder
thingies like does she think jerry is a
friendly hat
i think you sold it you are still
the most handsome man in the world to me
ugh mom come on yeah jeez
mom we're eating i know i mean it
doesn't make any sense
corporate uh wants somebody to be here
on saturday
and so we're gonna have to have a couple
people come in on the weekends and i
know nobody's gonna want to do it and
everybody's gonna
plane and i don't want to have to
deal with it and that's where you have
an assistant regional manager
yes it is assistant to the regional
manager same thing
no it's not it's lower so that's close
michael oh god come on i wanted to talk
to you about the downsizing there's no
downsizing
uh but if there were i'd be protected as
assistant regional manager assistant to
the regional manager
yep so i don't have to worry i am now
senpai
which is assistant sensei assistant to
the sensei that's pretty cool
assistant sensei okay by two o'clock
dwight will choose himself to be
assistant
to his own assistant me never been
arrested before
i mean i was detained once by taylor
swift's security team but that was a
misunderstanding
she's probably gonna write a song about
me point is hater's gone hate shake it
off taylor swift always right
i'm telling you this machine is broken
ask me a question
is jay-z really your favorite artist yes
obviously
lie see it's busted is it
or is your favorite artist really taylor
swift no
lie all right fine she is
she makes me feel things she makes all
of us feel things
this binder tells the story of a sloppy
disorganized irresponsible individual
who's not allowed within 500 feet
of taylor swift that was a
misunderstanding and you beautiful
tropical fish
oh and you beautiful naive sophisticated
newborn baby
what oh and you beautiful rule-breaking
moths
and you rainbow infused space unicorn
and you beautiful sassy mannequin come
to life
and you opalescent tree shark leslie you
are the master of the metaphor i
recently compared her to a nutrient-rich
chia seed i decided to give baby halpert
a newspaper from the day she was born
this frame set me back 55 bones
but she decided to take her sweet time
so now i have to switch it with today's
paper
indian guys always wear their cell
phones outside their pants it's so dorky
oh no no that's not dorky look it's
easily accessible
boom like this 9-1-1 hello scranton
strangler's in the house
inside the house
they caught the screen strangler they
trapped him in his house coming to you
from the corner of
columbia street in washington when is he
going to come out
what we all pray is the last but he's
wishing he had a hybrid
right 60 miles to the gallon in the city
no i bet he's wishing he was strangling
something okay that's our street
that's our street he's going down our
street okay everybody
there it is there it is i saw it where
wait inside it's gone
he went right by he missed it
you missed it what's the case toby well
i really can't talk about it but it's a
very high profile case is it criminal
yes have we heard of it i don't know is
it the middle school teacher who tried
to turn her a foreign exchange student
into a sex slave
come on was that the post office guy
rubbed his penis all over the mail guys
that's a really big
deal he's rubbing his neck he's rubbing
his neck he's rubbing his neck he's
rubbing his neck oh scran strangler
oh i can either confirm or deny this
let's just say i'll be up to my neck in
jury duty
this is the prison uh i am not going in
there with
expectations per se
i will meet george howard scub i will
tell him that i believe he is innocent
i would understand if he felt motivated
to hug me
i would understand if a friendship began
how did how did bogart put it
i think this is a star to my first
friendship
well the good news is no more guilty
conscience at least you know he is the
strangler
the proof is in the grip did they say
when the vocal cords would heal
one week okay
two weeks
okay and what's in the safe
the 21 million bing bots nope i was
gonna say bingo but then i was like
jackpot's better but then
it was too late i was halfway through
the word bing pop works it's taking off
it's taken off yeah
it's blood zone come on go go go
[Music]
oh santiago i
never mind what
a footprint you did it you brilliant
bimbo
pawnee's library department is the most
diabolical ruthless bunch of bureaucrats
i've ever seen
they're like a biker gang but instead of
shotguns
and crystal meth they use political
savvy
and shushing news flash we're screwed
we get a big problem with the library
punk ass book jockeys
wait why do we hate the library the
library is the worst group of people
ever assembled in history
they're mean conniving rude and
extremely well read which makes them
very dangerous
are you even listening to yourself
you're defending the library now ron
the library of all the horrifying
miserable things in the world
some people like libraries i can't even
believe what i'm hearing some people
like
libraries ron she's in your head
everything's fine we're just gonna chat
shouldn't you be at the library forcing
people to borrow books
i don't want him within 500 feet of the
library
it's good advice for all of us nothing
but trouble there
hi marcy leslie are they finally
teaching you parks people how to read
oh i guess not it's a movie you're
pretty cocky for someone whose job is
obsolete because of the internet
you seem to have a 40 late fee on a book
called mysteries of the female orgasm
no i don't yeah you do and grab the
movie
go go go go
you